un sous pression de la junte au pouvoir
à bamako paris ce serait donc résolu à
quitter le mali après neuf ans de lutte
anti djihad islamique ans et ses
partenaires européens s'apprêtent à
annoncer leur retrait du pays annonce
qui pourrait intervenir ce soir ou
demain en marge d'un sommet union
européenne union africaine prévue à
bruxelles antoine mariotti bonjour on va
plus loin avec vous aujourd'hui
concrètement at on une idée de ce que va
annoncer emmanuel macron il est très
probable que le président français
annonce un retrait total ou partiel en
tout cas assez important des forces
françaises qui sont actuellement
déployés au mali alors ce que ça veut
dire qu'elles vont quitter complètement
la région on sait bien que non que le le
problème ne se limite pas uniquement au
mali mais à l'ensemble du sahel
notamment la région des trois frontières
donc pour l'instant volé s'est payé la
sauce on le g5 sahel ce sont ceux qui
sont impliqués avec la france et les
pays européens d'ailleurs de la force
takouba pour lutter contre le terrorisme
islamiste donne dans la région faut
rappeler qu initialement au mali quand
la france est intervenu en 2013 c'est
parce qu'ils avaient une colonne qui
descendait en direction de bamako avec
le mali a appelé la france au secours
aujourd'hui évidemment ça c'est
davantage compliqué alors ils vont
quitter le mali mais jean yves le drian
le ministre français des affaires
étrangères dit qu'il ya d'autres pays
qui eux contrairement au mali sont tout
à fait demandeur d'avoir une présence
française pour continuer bien ce combat
contre les djihadistes et donc on y lira
a priori un redéploiement en termes de
commandement déjà mais peut-être aussi
de de force ce sera à voir dans les
heures évidemment qui viennent mais
notamment vers le niger le tchad où les
français sont déjà extrêmement présents
et puis surtout oui ces trois pays le
bénin le ghana et la côte d'ivoire ils
sont de plus en plus menacés par ce
problème jadis lille eu des attaques au
bénin la semaine dernière est
constamment un français qui est mort
mais d'autres personnes qui sont mortes
et donc il se pourrait que la france
propose ses services pour des pour
déployer davantage de militaires au
bénin en côte d'ivoire mais aussi même
si c'est un peu plus loin au sénégal où
il y à déjà évidemment des militaires
français alors leur allait forcément au
bilan antoine les français il se retire
sur quelle note exactement sur une autre
très contrastées évidemment le
immédiatement le ce que je rappais il ya
quelques instants en 2013 c'était une
une bonne cause d'intervenir au mali
sauver un pouvoir
mocratique stable et préserver la
stabilité de la région c'est aussi pour
ça que ça s'est développé au fur et à
mesure et puis certains vous disent
aujourd'hui dans la population quand on
interroge des gens mais il ya dix ans
par deux fois il ya dix ans on était en
sécurité aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le
cas mais parce que la menace djihadiste
a aussi augmenté en même temps et
c'était c'est l'éternel problème on l'a
vu en afghanistan on n'est pas armé
contre armée et c'est extrêmement
compliqué d'arriver à vaincre
entièrement bien quelque chose qui est
presque immatérielle parce qu'ils
peuvent se fondre voilà alors la
différence de l'afghanistan dont entend
parfois dire que finalement le sel c'est
notre afghanistan à nous nous français
c'est évidemment plus compliqué que ça
il y a des similitudes
c'est une une bonne cause au début et
puis finalement c'est une opération qui
dure dans le temps beaucoup trop
longtemps qu'ils aient finalement vu
comme une force d'occupation il ya des
résultats extrêmement contrastées parce
que la menace terroriste est toujours
extrêmement présente au sahel est
extrêmement forte peut-être même plus
forte qu il y a quelques années mais en
même temps c'est extrêmement différents
bamako n'est jamais tombé et puis on
tout n'est pas comparable donc c'est
très très contrastées même si on peut
voir chez nos confrères dans la presse
ou chez les chercheurs qu'il ya des mots
parfois extrêmement dur contre
l'opération barkan on devrait les
entendre ces mots on va évidemment sur
ce dossier en tout au long de la journée
demain également merci beaucoup antoine
pour le décryptage